foreign
it was a surprise visit he arrived early
by Chinook helicopter which landed on
the checkers lawn
Ukraine's President Vladimir zelenski in
his iconic car keys Rishi sunak in a
more traditional suit they look pleased
to see each other and hugs in front of
the waiting press because we're real
Partners Rishi knows all the details
what went on on our Battlefield
UK prime minister promised more military
aid to support Ukraine including
hundreds of air defense missiles and
hundreds more long-range attack drones
and president zelenski is still hoping
for more in the form of fighter jets we
want to create this and I see that in
the closest time you will hear some I
think were important decisions but we
have to work a little bit more on it
since the War Began the UK has donated
4.6 billion pounds in military aid to
Ukraine and experts believe it's been
essential in helping them fight back
against the Russian invasion the amount
of military and economic aid coming from
the United States from other NATO
countries has been essential to
Ukraine's ability to defend itself but
they are frustrated that the more
advanced weapons that they have been
asking for since the beginning of the
big invasion
always come after a long period of delay
but with the war now heading into its
second summer how long can the West keep
paying
I'm Leah belletto and this is the Sky
News Daily
[Music]
in a minute we're going to hear more
from former U.S ambassador to Ukraine
John Herbst about why he believes
continued military aid is the only way
to end the war but first let's talk to
our International Affairs correspondent
Dominic wagahorn who was at Checkers for
the meeting
yeah we're in a satellite truck parked
up of this Country Lane uh next to a
field some distance from Checkers but we
can see it but the atmosphere inside
earlier was it was fairly business-like
but I think you know that down the
street had laid on a show for him that
was laid in with symbolism I think it
was it was longer on symbolism than than
substance though and they chose to host
him here we overheard Rishi sunak saying
to president zielinski that he thought
it'd be better to get out here to have
the space to to have a proper chat over
both I think what Britain can do to help
Ukraine now but also the longer term
help that Britain wants to give Ukraine
so what was the symbolism for this
meeting being held at Checkers the prime
minister's country retreat
the reason it's symbolic is Checkers was
the wartime Retreat for Winston
Churchill and of course zelensky is a
man who is compared to Churchill so
often seen as the Churchill of our times
and so he arrived into his delegation
and he arrived in two Chinook
helicopters landing on the lawns in
front of of checkers and then they were
he was led into the Mansion itself and
taken to a room where sunak said that
Churchill had given some of his wartime
broadcasts on the radio
and then back out into the gardens after
they had a fairly lengthy tetar set and
bilateral meeting
through Checkers has some rather Fine
Formal Gardens and he was taken to the
edge of those and looked out over the
lawn again and Beyond those is an Avenue
of trees the victory Avenue it's called
These are Beech trees that were planted
by Winston Churchill at some point
during the war or afterwards so there
was a lot of symbolism and I think it
was it was designed to to sort of make
the most of zelenski's churchillion
credentials and possibly in the absence
of any more substantive help that
Britain can offer Ukraine at the moment
okay so Dominic what has Rishi sunak
actually promised Ukraine so what
Britain's offering at the moment uh in
addition to the long-range
precision-guided missiles that they
provided Storm Shadow and which possibly
were used for the first time over the
weekend there was a an attack well
Behind Enemy Lines that I think many
commentators May well think May well
have been a Storm Shadow missile in
addition to that Britain is offering
more anti-aircraft defense missiles and
more drones as well and also we heard
from the Prime Minister saying that
Britain wants to be part of the
Coalition of countries that will help
send fighter jets to Ukraine which would
be music to zelenski's ears except for
the fact there seems to be a longer term
ambition it's not something that's going
to happen anytime soon so Britain and
other Western nations are going to be
working together to send the the
advanced Western fighter jet jets that
the ukrainians want but not immediately
because they've got to train the fighter
pilots and although Britain's offered to
train fighter pilots that's not going to
begin until the summer so I think it's
helped that zelenski once wants to hear
about he's also been offered more
leopard tanks by the Germans on this
four Nation Tour of Europe he's just
been coming to the end of but I think
they would like to see more have more
sent their way and I think there's some
doubt about how effective they're
counter-offensive against the Russians
can be until they get more of those kind
of advanced weapons they're asking for
and Dominic you mentioned there you know
zelenski is going on this charm
offensive in-person meeting with leaders
in Germany in France in Italy and
obviously here in the UK with sunac what
do you make of this tour in particular
your thoughts on zelenski's relationship
with sunap because we know that his
relationship with Boris Johnson appeared
to be very close
yeah there was a genuine kind of uh
Rapport and Chemistry Between Boris
Johnson and president zielinski that was
it went beyond just to help Britain was
was giving Ukraine and that Johnson
brought to to the war but it's also it
was a very personal chemistry clearly
between the two leaders I think Richard
seem like someone who just he doesn't
know as well and he's getting to know
but clearly they get on very well there
was a lot of laughter between them a lot
of bonami
um and zelensky he's a very Charming Man
he's very clever and capable of I think
being all things to all men so as we've
seen as we've seen with his oratory in
different occasions he tailors his words
depending on the audience he's uh
speaking to I think that happens also
one-on-one as well
um and clearly the two get on get on
well but I think there is a frustration
amongst ukrainians not so much with
Britain but other European leaders are
not being as forthcoming as they might
have been and even though they are now
playing catch up it's it's coming a
little bit too late so for instance the
Germans who it took a huge amount of
persuasion to agree to send leopard's
modern battle tanks have now kind of got
to the point where they're saying to
other countries if you've got these
tanks they need to be sent so kind of
making up for it they now have more than
200 uh battle tanks which will give them
considerable capability whenever this
counter-offensive begins but I think
there is a sense that it's all coming a
little bit too late so it's fair to say
that there's been a lot of promises to
Ukraine at this meeting but maybe they
shouldn't expect to receive much of it
anytime soon I think along with other
Western Nations the cover but he's
beginning to become a little bear in
terms of what the UK can spare at this
stage I think there's a worry across
across the west and in America as well
that if they give the ukrainians too
much
they won't have enough left in terms of
precision guided missiles in terms of
advanced Weaponry for other
eventualities maybe China attacking
Taiwan or other possible threats down
the line and Dominic what do you think
are the reservations from Western allies
about arming Ukraine because they'll be
trying to I suppose tread a line between
supporting Ukraine and avoiding
escalating tensions with Russia
yeah I think there's a there's a balance
there and the and the fears are that
either Putin is forced into a corner
where he uses more extreme methods so
either uses nuclear weapons which he's
kind of threatened to a number of times
a number of other Russian officials have
as well or there are a number of other
things he could do he could attack
undersea cables he could attack the kind
of Internet arteries of the world or the
or more gas pipelines under the sea and
all that could be very damaging
economically so I think there's there's
a fear of of what this could do to Putin
if he's backed into corner and he's been
very effective at exploiting that fear
so I think when you've got the Hawks and
the doves in Washington and other
European capitals deciding at various
stages during this war how much they
give the ukrainians that's been the kind
of tension giving them enough to repel
this Invasion but not enough to back
Putin into a corner where he acts in a
desperate way I think there's another
fear though as well which is that if the
ukrainians are too successful and they
resoundingly beat the Russians say to
the point where where they lose Crimea
then that's a job ending scenario for
Putin and Putin is so established at the
top of what he's called himself the
power verticals of his government he's
enmeshed himself in all the security
agencies all the branches of governments
or the intelligence agencies that if he
was threatened if he was removed from
Power because of the job-ending scenario
of losing Crimea if the leadership in
Russia went to him and said you've got
to go I think the fear possibly is of
Chaos in Russia kind of vacuum emerging
that could see the Russian Federation
disintegrating and then this this
nuclear superpower becoming more of a
sort of dysfunctional Rogue State I
think that is certainly a fear in the
west as well and do you think that's
something that Rishi sunak and other
world leaders are saying to ukrainians
that they want to support them but they
have to tread this line but I think if
you talk to ukrainians they say well
those are valid fears but we have to
beat him resoundingly and decisively so
that he can't do this again their fear
is that Putin is allowed allowed to keep
Crimea are allowed to keep parts of the
donbass and then if therefore he has
land from which he could do this all
over again
and I think we're beginning to get to a
point where the west and Ukraine is
trying to find a way out of this and I
think the tensions between all those
points is what's going to be kind of
fought over and wrestled over between
Ukraine and and the West
and I think the sense we have at the
moment is the Ukraine's not going to be
given enough to decisively beat the
Russians not to expel them from Crimea
or donbass I think the question is then
what happens next does that give enough
to the Russians to buy their time waste
a few more years and attack Ukraine
again or can the ukrainians be given
enough to reassure them say maybe a kind
of de facto membership of NATO if not a
full-on formal membership of NATO so I
think there's the tensions between the
Western Ukraine as they kind of
deliberate over to how they try and
bring the cerebral War to an end
[Music]
the UK is the second biggest donor of
military aid to Ukraine only the U.S has
spent more in the last few years and
they along with other NATO Powers see it
as vital for their own security that
Putin doesn't win in Ukraine and that's
why they're happy to send billions John
Herbst is a former U.S ambassador to
Ukraine and now runs the Eurasia Center
at the Atlantic Council Think Tank
so John hello to you just how important
is it to the West that Ukraine wins this
war with Russia the the West has a vital
interest in this war
Putin has an aggressive foreign policy
designed to re-establish control over
most of the space if not all the space
of the former Soviet Union
if he were to win his war in Ukraine we
have to worry about him committing
aggression in other countries of the
former Soviet Union like Kazakhstan of
Georgia but also in countries other
countries that were under moscow's
control like Estonia Latvian Lithuania
which happened to be NATO members
the smart place to deal with Putin's
aggressive foreign policies Ukraine a
large country fighting brilliantly and
bravely against overwhelming odds but
odds that we shortened by providing
military assistance to Ukraine a lot was
promised over the weekend to Ukraine why
do you think now is it being asked for
and how significant is the aid that has
been promised well the aid that the West
has provided and has promised to provide
to Ukraine has been essential for its
victories on the battlefield but Ukraine
is asking for more advanced weapons
that actually the United States
principally or too timid to send
thank goodness the British decided to
send Storm Shadow just like thank
goodness months ago British decided to
send its Challenger tanks because up
until the British decision on tanks
timidity in Berlin and Washington was
preventing the sending of Western tanks
to Ukraine
the Brits embarrassed Washington and
Germany and thank goodness for that
Ukraine has been asking for long-range
fires missiles or Rockets with a range
of up to 300 kilometers the United
States here too has been too timid to
send it the Brits decided over the past
week to send Storm Shadow with a range
of 250 kilometers and hopefully too this
will knock Washington out of its
complacency so it two cents the longer
range fires Ukraine needs well Ukraine
has been asking for military aid
specifically aircraft you know since the
beginning of this war and also I wonder
as a former Ambassador you must be
hearing from people inside the country I
mean what are they saying about the
support that they're being given
well they are grateful because they
understand that the amount of military
and economic aid coming from the United
States from other NATO countries from
the EU has been essential to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself but they are
frustrated that the more advanced
weapons that they have been asking for
since the beginning of the big invasion
always come after a long period of delay
and after many refusals to send the
weapons
that was true with the high Mars
artillery with a range of 85 kilometers
which Washington only decided to send in
June of last year
the ukrainians were taking a massive
punishment from the Russians in donbass
from early spring until we sent those
High Mars and they immediately allowed
Ukraine to go on the offensive
now we see a similar timidity in
Washington when it comes to sending the
longer range fires the f-16s and I don't
have any doubt that if we were to
provide those things Ukraine could
launch another major Contour offensive
do you think that continuing with
military aid is the best way to end the
war then
sadly it's the only way
despite his many defeats in Ukraine
Putin retains his original objective
which to establish effective political
control over the country
he's not going to settle for what he's
taken thus far and nor should Ukraine
have to accept Russia gets to keep those
territories that it has already seized
so Putin thinks that he can Outlast the
West he understands that our Aid has
been essential to Ukraine's defense he
thinks we will grow tired of this and
that short-sighted people in the west
will refuse to see that Putin's
objectives go beyond Ukraine
so it would be strategically foolish for
us to stop sending the weapons we send
to Ukraine the United States has
provided about 55 billion dollars of Aid
a year for the last couple of years to
Ukraine looked at by itself that seems
like an enormous amount of money but
that money both that economic and
military aid represents about six
percent of our defense budget with that
six percent of our defense budget
Ukraine has destroyed approximately 50
percent of moscow's conventional
military capacity that's a very strong
investment in American and Western
Security
but surely there's a limit to how much
military aid can be provided to Ukraine
I mean the UK and the US they have their
own defenses to think about you know
there's only so much the West can do
well that's an interesting way to phrase
it and the only way you can be phrase
that way if we fail to recognize the
danger that Putin represents
you know before the United States
entered World War II there were
isolationist voices saying this was not
an American fight
and they were saying we can't afford to
send those old destroyers to Britain
because you know we were in a Great
Depression
but in fact had we not sent those old
destroyers had we not done Len lease
the cost in the United States and
defeating in this case Germany's
aggression they've been far greater than
it was
one of the problems with Western
leadership in this fight especially
Washington's leadership they refused to
Define to the American people the
Americans stake in this war
Putin has said he wants to restore
moscow's control over all the space it
used to make of the former Soviet Union
that means if Putin pursues these
objectives which he will if he wins in
Ukraine
means that he may well be taking
aggressive actions against our NATO
allies the Baltic states so we might
find ourselves in a fighting war with
Russia
if you define it this way the problem of
moscow's aggression is not just his war
in Ukraine it's the problem of
containing a rogue nuclear power
and that is something which is very
dangerous to our security that Rogue
nuclear power but also up to our
prosperity in which case providing again
55 billion dollars a year from the
United States to Ukraine for years to
come is not a great expense
would you ever see a situation where
there would be boots on the ground in
Ukraine fighting Russian forces I don't
think that's necessary the ukrainians
have every reason to fight this fight
because they're fighting for their lives
as ukrainians they have proved to be
able give them the means give them the
weapons and not one western boot needs
to land in Ukraine to fight this war
so John from your point of view How
likely is it that Ukraine can win this
war
I think that as long as Western support
anchored in the United States
remains at least what it is Ukraine will
win this war
but if we were to overcome our community
and send the attacks send the f-16s
Ukraine would deliver a crushing defeat
on Kremlin forces and this would
eventually lead to a change in Kremlin
objectives and a real piece a just piece
a stable piece only a stable peace
serves our interests and that means
Moscow ending its war of aggression in
Ukraine accepting Ukraine's right to
choose its own political and economic
system as well as its own International
relationships
and strong support from the West in
terms of weapons and hopefully a seat in
NATO membership in NATO so Moscow
understands it has to cease aggression
my thanks to John Herbst and Dominic
wagorn and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Leah belletto
this episode was produced by Rosie
gilletts and Amy Lakin our editor is
Philly Beaumont
[Music]